Maronna virus pandemic has put a
spotlight on the long-lasting social
inequalities race issues and increased
deprivation within the black Asian and
minority ethnic community and it's
happened through the disproportionate
deaths of thousands of people and so now
an inquiry will be carried out by the
equality and Human Rights Commission to
look further into this huge concern we
need to ensure that equality issues are
absolutely at the center of the response
long term to this coronavirus it's sad
that it's taken the coronavirus to get
the degree of attention that we now have
but I still think irrespective of what
hasn't happened historically that now is
the time to act the inquiry comes after
a report commissioned by the government
which failed to offer recommendations on
how to protect pame lives during the
pandemic in the commons yesterday the
equalities minister admitted the public
health England review was published with
gaps in it there was more that I would
have been hoping to see but I do
understand that Phe did not have all the
data that it needed some of the things
that one president included
comorbidities population density public
transport news household point for the
composition housing conditions that is
why it is important that I take this
forward but many people from this
community which has been hurting
disproportionately right from the start
of this outbreak say actions should have
been taken earlier when at least 12
different reports came to the same
conclusion labor who've called for an
independent inquiry are still angry no
actions have been implemented it will
actually begin to start to talk about
and and you know come up with some
strong recommendations about what action
the government must take you know at the
end of the day I believe at this moment
they are letting down the be AME
community the government say they're
committed to leveling up as their
equalities have developed these findings
this new inquiry obviously won't bring
back the lives of those who've succumbed
to the virus but for some families it
will be an element of comfort as it
looks to tackle the deep-rooted
inequalities that have plagued this
community
for years in demand Rasheed Sky News